bienvenue à titanyen prison spatiale de
haute sécurité
nous sommes équipés des toutes dernières
technologies ville est haussière de toi
dis moi ton côté vous serez le colisée
sacchi 24 heures ce matin ne sont
générés par échapper
on ne conduit pas un cyril ça se voit
que tu es nouvelle la prison c'est pas
le bâtiment c'est la planète toute
entière
votre réduction de peine vous
n'obtiendrez si vous rallier la base
nord afin d'y réparer le générateur
principal
l'échec n'est pas une option c'est du
suicide
tout est hostile cieux on ne tiendra
jamais mieux les températures sont
glaciales
ces choses-là je connais un moyen de se
tirer un drôle yucatan droit n'existe
pas 7
zend ceux qui croient survivront
ces prix gagner le mans mais rodez
enclencher les protocoles 4
ta faute il ya forcément un moyen fuir